hello and
uh welcome to pydata global 2021
uh my name is ajit kumar i am very happy
to be here so i will be moderating this
workshop session so i will give a brief
about professor lou he is currently a
senior data scientist
of uh
best health institute in la jolla
non-profit medical organization so he
have nearly 25 years of experience doing
data science and machine learning so you
will be happy to know that he had
completed his phd some uh
20 19
1998 that's like now 24 5 years so
we are very happy to welcome you dr lou
so now i will hand over session to you
all right so uh first thing is i'm going
to show you an example of some of the
visualizations i've been able to do with
dash leaflet and then go into some of
the basics i'm not quite sure what all
your backgrounds are
as far as i don't know
but i'm kind of assuming you you know
you know how to do some python but you
may be unfamiliar with dash and um
and probably not um maybe not that
familiar with geographic data
so to start off with uh
what
while you guys are um
trying to get the docker notebook up
this is a visualization
basically it's how i spent last
christmas uh we were
on a project where we were trying to
provide a tool for decision makers for
this the vaccine rollout for kova that
was about to take place so you got to
bear in mind covid was raging at this
time vaccines were not actually out yet
but
logistics was going to be a big deal so
what this
map does is it actually shows you
possible types of sites
that
that could distribute vaccines and so
i'm not going to get too much into the
detail of this
the notebook that says getting started
has the link to the actual site if you
actually want to read about this i just
kind of want to show you the
interactions that we're capable of
so for instance at this sort of national
level you can navigate by clicking on a
state and it would actually
also select the menu would filter the
data based on the state
i can click another state of a traverse
over there uh another feature here is
the the the sites are actually clustered
so when they're really close together a
different marker is used as opposed to
the standard marker so this indicates
that there are four
here uh
four different potential sites
uh within each of these are tool tips
and
let's see what else is there you could
also select focus in on a particular
county
um i've also added a reset button to get
back to the top of the map and
let's see kansas is usually a good
example
also i implemented
menus that are filters here that will
actually let you select this type of
site
so that's kind of just to give you a
flavor and most of these things um if we
time permitting will cover enough of the
building blocks that you can probably
figure out how to do something like this
all right um
okay so
so again here's the link to that
visualization it's actually embedded in
iframe so it's a little bit smaller and
i
ran it locally just because it would
fill my screen and i could actually
control the dimensions
okay
so um
a quick introduction to dash
um
so dash is actually intended to be sort
of uh
to develop data-driven web applications
it's actually produced
by
or it's a open source project but back
heavily by
plotly
and so
it's very convenient for taking data and
graphing it
so uh without getting too deep into that
i'm just going to
mentioned
the the two basic things is that dash
has has these uh
components they're very similar to react
components if anybody is on the web
development side of things
if not you don't really need to worry
about it's basically a web object
and
so bash has two
basic parts to it
you have the layouts which
very much mimic how you would lay out a
web page
if if you are um
comfortable you know with html then this
would be very
basic but we're not going to go into any
really complicated structures here
because essentially this is all about
the maps and so we'll have a
map component and the layout will
in most of the cases will simply be
map and then maybe a button
the other big aspect of dash is the
callbacks
and i don't
the way the callbacks work is each
component
has properties and so properties can
serve as inputs
outputs or
states
and so for instance of a button there's
a property called nclix which is the
number of times it's been clicked
and that increments every time a button
is clicked and if you take it as an
input it is actually
the um
it will return that that number as as
that variable so that's how the
um
that's how the uh
the call but the function the callback
function actually receives it
so for this workshop um i'm just going
to go
oh
i should
i'm not going to read this i guess you
guys can read it at your own leisure
if you want to
um
but for this workshop uh i i'm using
something called jupiter dash it
actually allows you to embed a
note
a dash application inside a jupiter
notebook
so here are some of the basic
uh
imports you need just for the operation
of this workshop uh turns out i think
something with jupiter dash actually
broke with the
with the proxy if you're running the the
contain of the notebook it's important
that uh you use the proxy because uh
you're only going to be exposing one
port um
so anyhow um so these two lines you
really don't have to worry about this is
very
idiosyncratic to this particular
work uh workbook i never quite figured
out in time how to
fix the need for this next cell so it's
just just
taken on faith
uh the reason those two are in separate
cells for some reason timing thing
what this basically does is oh
the way this works is
dash actually runs off its own port
because it's really a built on top of
flask and if you're not familiar it's
just basically a web server so there's a
port associated with that
and so what this does is it basically
allows you to reuse the same port that
your jupiter is using otherwise you have
to open up more ports for each of these
all right so this is a very basic
app
all it is is a there's an input field in
the output field
um
and
basically
if i change something here it mirrors on
it basically takes the input and throws
into the output that's all this callback
does and so this is a very simple
demonstration of how this callback
structure works
uh again the i'm just bringing this up
as an example
this is how you end up building
interactions say between a map and
your data or vice versa but we're not
going to go very deep in
the examples here
the last thing i mentioned here is the
way i'm doing this is
the
dash server has to have a port
associated with it i'm just telling it
to pick one at random
the reason for that is that way i can
have multiple
servers running in my notebook so if i
go back to one it'll still be working
the alternative way to do it and i have
the example down here is you could
actually set the port
and
um
let's see
this does the exact same thing it's the
same app except by just handling the
port a little differently
and what i can do then is this command
here will actually tell it to shut down
the server so if you don't want to have
a lot of these processes running because
these will all correspond to another
process on your
computer you can do it this way
okay so that's sort of uh i
think that's the end of the sort of the
preliminaries i want to know does
anybody
um need a little more time to catch up
here or that wants to get the notebook
up i'm going to look at the chat here so
otherwise i'll
move forward
okay
uh did i ask for let's get another
minute uh in the meantime bring up the
next notebook uh this is actually
well i can start i can talk about data
sources well
to give you guys a little more time
a lot of times you're going to get data
that's
say
it's geographically
oriented but you won't have say
the geometries to
to draw the draw the maps a great place
to get that is the u.s census bureau
there are maps for everything look for
the word uh cartographic boundary files
and i have brought it up
here just to show you
so you can do things like you get county
maps you can get congressional districts
uh
all kinds of different divisions um i
believe school
at least if you go with specific states
you can get school districts different
kinds of subdivisions
uh yeah school districts uh legislative
districts
um
so for whatever purpose you can probably
find almost any kind of
breakdown and
the reason you need this is that you
gotta build tell
the
leaflet
how to draw the particular regions
and
in the data that
the notebook or the github repo i have
included the
county and a state
map and
since they're from the u.s census bureau
pretty much unrestricted use on those
okay so i'm going to go ahead and start
talking a little bit about
geographic data
the two formats that dash leaflet uses
are called geojson
and geobuff
now geojson is really and this will also
extend into what i'm going to mention
about geodata frames um
i hope
nobody is
i mean i hope you guys have a little
familiarity with at least what pandit's
data frames are
again we won't go into a whole lot of
depth there but a
little basic knowledge helpful here
okay so really geojson
and geodata frames are
pretty much the same as their
counterparts a json and a
and a data frame the difference is that
in the geojson or geodata frame there's
a column or an attribute called
geometry
okay so let's go ahead and load a data
frame here this is from the county data
frame from the census bureau
i'm not even exactly sure what all of
these
other things
attributes are but the key things is the
name of the county
um
the states are encoded in something
called the
fips code which i will talk about later
oh i should back up i know this is an
international conference and
and um i am very u.s centric with a lot
of this data
so
you probably have to i'm sure
other countries have similar resources
available and the format the data file
format should be the same
the nice thing about the us census
bureau for the u.s maps is that the
zip
uh these zip files can actually be
loaded directly into geo pandas oh and i
did i should mention geopandas is
basically an extension of geopa pandas
that
understands geographic data
so um
so the main thing to note is that there
is this geometry column which is
something that's
characteristic of all geopanda
data frames
and what this geometry column actually
is it's
from another library called the shapely
it
really uh
and you can look up you know if you want
to delve deeper into this you can
basically it consists of four types of
objects polygons
multi-polygons points and multi points
so for the census data and i just happen
to pick this one because i know which
one it is that's san diego county this
is where uh west health institute is
and if you actually matplotlib which
comes as part of jupiter will actually
show you
the shape
and this is from alaska i believe
oh what happened there
okay
um
yeah state code two uh and this i just
wanted to give you this this is an
example of a multi-polygon which is
basically two disjoint
shapes um and most likely what this is
is that this is probably these are
probably islands or something
okay and at least for u.s data i would
recommend especially for states and
counties using these fips codes which
it's just a way of avoiding
confusion between similar names or
misspellings um
every county and every state
and territory i believe in the us has a
code
and for this it makes it a lot easier to
join and quite often geographic data is
given this way
all right um
really there is a question about is
there a standard for sharing geodata i
at this point
i
i'm not really uh familiar about uh stan
share um
what that means if you're talking about
like being able to um
this this fips code is one way at least
for u.s
regions
of kind of standardizing uh how you
represent a particular geographic region
okay so i think at this point this is
where we will start
delving a little deeper into the
notebook so far these have been pretty
lightweight as far as
anything you might want to do
activity wise i i really haven't shown
you anything that
you know that where you really would
want to necessarily play around with but
we're going to start getting into the
so i just
i guess i could take a few questions
right now and just to make sure we
give everyone time to get the images
running
if not i will go ahead and
yes so participants if you have any
question you can ask in chat
so i will forward
otherwise we will continue
like have you set up your environment
are you able to download
the image docker image
so if it is like you can just reply
inside so we'll be
knowing what is the progress so that
will help dr lou to continue and just so
you know i do have in another uh monitor
i do have the chat window up so when i
do have time i can take a glance at it
and this is okay
you can put your question inside thank
you
all right so i will go ahead and move on
to the uh
there was a question about um whether it
has to be geojson um
other formats i mean the the shape files
i
hadn't really gotten into the them in
detail
the shape files of the us census bureau
doesn't
um
it isn't isn't a geo-json it actually uh
there's some formats i don't even
remember what they're called
but
it just turns out that geopandas
is equipped to parse that type
and what i would find out is that
for a lot of the countries there's a
question about
or mentioned that a lot of countries
have
gis and other shape files available i
think
geopandas is pretty just like pandas is
very
good at reading different formats of
data i believe geopandas
uh is really good about
parsing out the
the different types of shape files
and
what ends up happening is that
you know you'll see in my pattern here
that i'll convert the geodata frames
into geojson so the the source i'm using
from the census bureau
is
the the source
i'm using for the sense of bureau is not
geo-json i'm actually reading it in
using geopandas and it
figures it out and then i'm using
geopandas to convert it to geojson
well i guess just just to give
a little more time for the image if
someone's still trying to pull the image
i did i did mention did not mention what
geo buff is that's another format that
leaflet will use
which is actually think of it as sort of
a
compressed binary form
i looked at the code and really it is
some kind it's just a format conversion
because uh jason
bitwise is not it
it's not very efficient right there's a
lot of you're using first of all you're
using ascii characters there's a lot of
delimiting characters
this compresses it and it
the way
dash works is most of the data
ultimately gets pushed out to your
browser
so you kind of want to streamline if
you're thinking about performance you do
want to streamline what you push out so
that's the reason for bringing geo buff
here uh you probably don't want to
manipulate using geo buff
but uh it's sort of like your last
last step before you push things out
okay so um
okay uh all right so i'll go into dash
let's start talking about dash leaflet
and i do want to point out one thing um
i have no affiliation with the open
source dash leaflet project i just
happen to find it very useful and learn
quite a lot about it and that's why i've
proposed this workshop to kind of share
that knowledge
[Music]
all right well actually we got one
question let me let me take that before
i go on
actually it's a good question about how
clean it is and one of the issues
i ran into
is
you'll see it at the end of one of these
sections i call it the anti-meridian
problem and that is
it's not so much the data is incorrect
it's just that when you
leaflet does not interpret it correctly
because of the way it
draws the maps
this happens when you have territories
that split across
the 180 degree
longitude line
because on one side it's minus 179 say
and on the other side it's 179.
and so it'll actually draw it on
opposite ends of the map and that
actually causes problems especially if
you're trying to zoom in and you you'll
see that i think it's on
probably on lesson four because i
mentioned that
in detail i've not really had
um
issues at least from the census bureau
uh one thing
i'll digress again just to answer this
question um one thing you'll notice here
on the census data is that you have this
these various size files and that
actually has to do with the resolution
of the geometry they're providing you
um
you notice that this county one on the
top has 11 megs whereas the one on the
bottom is less than one
and that just means that you know all
the contours are in far greater detail
on the top one so so in a sense i mean
you get to choose
uh
how
accurate you want it
um
okay so with that said let's get on to
dash leaflet
one of the reasons i
discovered dash leaflet is that
performance wise for the project i had
mentioned we tried different things
but at the end of the day we knew we'd
have to just deploy this as a public
tool
and so things like uh ipai leaflet and
some others that attempt to use that
were just did not have the performance
and that's the main reason for doing
this plus we have a movement here at
work to move more towards using dash as
our
visualization platform
all right so um
i'll start this out
so i'm going to start the notebook with
the usual
all right
i mentioned before
dash deals with components and so the
first two components we're going to talk
about
are
the map and tile layer the third one the
one that we're going to get the mo
probably hit over and over again is the
geo json layer
so
i'm not going to go into it here
now i've listed out all the options that
can go all the properties i should say
that go with this map object and there
are quite a few
i'm only going to call out a few that
are
kind of important
the most important ones
um
so uh
style will
style you i use mostly for
you know
deciding what the dimensions of my map
are zoom is it kind of
tells you sort of what zoom level you
want to initially
uh show your map center shows you where
it should be centered and bounds will uh
kind of tell you the
bounds is another way of kind of setting
the zoom in center
it's
so
and that was sort of the trick i used on
my map when i wanted to use the menu to
drive
uh which county or state i picked
uh okay so
the first kind of exercise this is just
very basic the the first thing
is
this code basically will draw a map and
i just
pick the particular style
now it turns out
if by default it centers
on denmark and at
this particular zoom level and even here
you know it comes
with a um
these zooming arrows so you can kind of
go in and out
and you know you can take a minute to
to play with it you have a grabber so
you can
move
and
you know let's say
i pick a spot and i keep zooming in this
actually
the way it works is that there are
different resolution tiles that you're
actually getting from a tile server so
you can get actually fairly detailed
when you zoom way in
there so this is sort of the kind of
interaction just just very basic out of
the box and at this point i haven't
done anything except um
add it
i'll get into this tile layer but if i
just created a map element it's
essentially an empty container it's very
much like uh for those of you familiar
with html it's very much like a div
an all-purpose kind of catch-all the
only thing that's different it has a
bunch of properties that are very useful
such as the the zoom and the center
those are attributable to the the map
the tile layer is what draws all these
pictures which is essentially the tiles
so this is getting pretty deep somewhere
in france i
honestly don't
was it france or germany uh anyway
uh
and so
you can play with that um now
for a lot of the visualizations i use
the us is the center
uh
so
uh what i will do is i will take
this sort of the pattern i i'm in a lot
of these cases i'm going to
keep adding on to
the
primary example
but in order to
let you know sort of how we kind of
finish in this case there's not that
much to do but to kind of let you know
how i'm going to finish up
i've created a i'll have a cell here
which is not executable it's and then be
a raw and be convert cell
but that'll show you the final state of
the code after all the playing i do so
that um you'll have kind of the you know
if you reset this you'll have my start
point my finish point and then you can
play around all you want in the middle
all right so
it just turns out after some
i think i actually
took this from
the dash leaflet documentation but this
is the centers the u.s and puts it the
continental u.s and puts it at a
reasonable zoom rate
okay so
um
i'll give you guys a minute to
play around with that uh you can you
know you can change i could start out
change the zoom to seven which will
probably probably put me somewhere in
kansas in the middle
[Music]
yeah
and
get
even more detailed if i want to
okay
um
let me
pause for a moment anybody have
questions or difficulties with this so
far i mean i just want this is very
basic as far as the dash leaflet but i
just want to make sure if you're having
issues with the notebooks
give a minute
and
all right well you can break in before
we finish the next exercise if you're
having trouble or maybe slow down
okay so um
the next layer i'll talk about the tile
layer this is the one that actually is
responsible for that underlying map
by default it uses uh the openstreetmap
now there's a link here included in the
notebook if you uh i could bring it up
actually
this actually is sort of a wiki that
gives a list of a bunch of tile servers
some commercial some
some free
some of them are
regional
and some of them are
worldwide so
you can find your different maps
here um
so if you're kind of wondering where you
get
the uh
these uh find these tile services one
place
theoretically if you get
really motivated you can actually
you know
create your own tile server
uh that
seems like way too much work but uh it's
a i have heard of people doing that and
that's part of this open street map
project you can always contribute your
tiles back to them
all right so uh
oh and i should mention as well
before i get too deep into this i
thought i had included a slide
it's always good to know where to look
try to look for answers
so there is
the leaflet documentation is actually
pretty good at describing most of these
properties you'll find so like for
instance this one will tell me
for the tire layers what my those
properties are so because i won't you
know i don't have time to go through
every property and to be honest you know
half of them which i don't use i
actually don't know what they do
uh the other place to look for is
i thought i had it up here but
leaflet
also has their own documentation now it
i'm
this is
you could think of it more as a bunch of
examples because he doesn't go through a
lot of explanation very well
and you'll see that i lifted some of my
examples off of this page so
but those are two good places
i'll go ahead and post that one to the
chat because i did not include
the documentation
um
all right so
um
so i've included the actual explicit url
for the this is actually the default
and i'll explain the little curly braces
what those mean too because
basically i believe x and y is i think
fairly self-evidence the x y coordinates
but
z i believe is sort of the zoom level
and then s is a
it's the server if you noticed on the
tile server page there's some that might
some of these will list a b and c
so this this let me highlight it this
one shows a b and c so that's sort of a
wild card so it can randomly pick the
appropriate server
um
you really don't need to know how what
that is but
only that you need to keep it in here in
the url
all right so this is the this map
doesn't look any different than the one
i gave in the first example
um
[Music]
see uh
one of the things okay so the two
properties uh i wanted to mention about
the tile layer because for the most part
there's not a whole lot um
you
need to customize you pick this the tile
server you like and you pick
them
and you can
use the url for that the other thing
which is kind of important in our line
of work as data people is that you know
all data should be properly attributed
so there's this attribution property
and i'll take my attribution from here
this and it's a
it's an html and a lot of times the map
producers will actually give you
this is not copy maybe
the map producers do not
will actually give you the attribution
html
oops and then then i would add this as a
property to my
and so what does this actually do
it
generates this down here in the corner
and
basically it says this map data is from
openstreetmap and it's uh the creative
commons
licensing
now um
just so that you can see something a
little interesting
a little different this is a different
tile map
you'll see this is quite different this
is a topographical map
still gets down to like when you get
down to the street level
you'll still see i mean
if you get down deep enough you do get
down to the street level but it does
have all the
topographical features
um
those are the two basic
you know free maps that i i found there
there are a few others that are sort of
free or sort of in the freemium model
but
that's basically that
okay so this is just playing with maps
and has nothing to do with data so far
uh just allows you to draw maps and
and um
let's see it allows you to draw maps and
allows you to manipulate them to some
degree
okay so i will uh i'll take a little
break
a question came up someone was asking
about matt box um
okay
well
i think well one thing is map bop map
box if you use that that's uh it's sort
of under freemium model so it turns out
you have to use a license
uh
key and a few other things to even if
you're using it for free
um
we did try mapbox but for some reason
for performance it didn't work as well
maybe we weren't using it right but at
the time
this was just before the christmas
holidays and we wanted to try to get
something out before the new year's and
so we were just searching for solutions
that were fast
um this functionality actually is um
there's quite a lot of this and you'll
see later on that there's no getting
around pushing a lot of this
functionality and
using some javascript
and so
you'll just need to know enough
javascript to be dangerous but to to
really use this
okay
so
now back to the exercise the real bread
and butter here is going to be this uh
geojson layer
it's um
this is where your data
uh meshes with all this map stuff so
we've talked all about this
uh
the maps but you know this would be a
visualization if you're not going to
represent data somehow on a map
okay so the key property
the the most most important property are
these data properties
now data
you provide as a uh either in this
geojson dimension or geobuff
format and really there's just a helper
function that could convert geojson to j
uh geobuff
and i believe in his doc the the dash
lisa documentation he actually gives a
benchmark comparison
and by far
uh gioba uh geobuff is faster
mainly because you push the actual
data you're pushing from your your
backend server to the browser is much
smaller
the other possible way of
representing that your data is through a
url you could actually specify a url so
it pulls that and
[Music]
as opposed to you pushing it out from
your um
from your dash server
uh i did notice one pattern uh about
these properties
if it has a strange camel case uh it is
actually one of the native react
components that is represented in
leaflets so you would look at the
leaflet documentation
if it uses this kind of lowercase
underscore like click feature that is
something that was added for the purpose
of dash leaflet and so you would look in
the dash leaflet documentation so if you
have trouble that's one of the problems
i
he basically defers most of the options
back to the leaflet documentation so
unless it's one of these
underscore features
uh
you you probably need to find the
property in dash leaflet but i'm going
to go through the one at least the
properties i think are the most
important
um
speaking of those underscore features
these three are kind of the ones you
want if you want to build interactions
so say that you want to click something
on the map and if you click a feature
which is either state or
a point which might be a city
and you may want to drive some other
part of your visualization we're not
going to get into that kind of elaborate
stuff here
but
you know if you want to do a cross
filter where you have a graph on the
right side and a
in the map on the left and you want to
use
the map to drive
the graph on the right
you could connect it using this click
feature and the click feature when i
mentioned the
callbacks can be used as an input and
that input will provide you with the uh
basically the row that that that
represents that feature in your
in your data frame so if it's the
estate say california
it'll give you everything in
california's row
hover feature is very similar to click
feature this just has to do with
when you actually hover over
a um
a feature as opposed to clicking on it
it's just
what triggers the behavior
and
nclix is more of a rudimentary one i
probably wouldn't use that i just bring
it up here because these are the three
interaction properties in the geojson
layer
zoom properties
actually that's how you do some of the
very basic navigation zoom to data
and
zoom to bound on click we'll i'll play
with the latter one
here but
we'll talk more about zoomed about in
the next
in the next section
okay so again i'm going to load the i'm
going to load the state data this time
and
okay so a little word about the data
here
the
geodata frame
has a function called has a method
called json which actually produces a
json string
but you actually want
the for
dash leaflet you want to represent it as
a python dictionary so
i use the json library to then load this
string
so that this result let me go ahead and
just show
so if you look at this
data frame
you'll see that
it starts
and ends with a single quote
so this is actually a string it is not a
python object so by doing this
json
load s which basically loads a
json string into a python dictionary
now this is a proper python
dictionary
so that's uh i just kind of wanted to
mention that
in case
you know you you go through this and you
you're on your own and you stick the
data frame you do it to json and you're
like why doesn't this work
and
so that's an important step to remember
uh
okay so this is the us now that
shapefile i have you can see that it has
actually
drawn an outline
on the
on the different states
and i will
um
i'll go get into some of the zooming
features a little more
later i figured out my problem i
have a really weird arrangement on my
desk and getting to the keyboard
sometimes
customy problem now i figured out how to
configure it right zoom to bounds on
click was i believe the property i
mentioned above
if i actually add that and feel free to
do the same okay it won't do anything
different as far as drawing but now when
i click on a feature
it zooms to that particular feature
and centers it and picks the appropriate
zoom level so if i go over here to rhode
island which is small
it'll magnify it and then if i
say pick a bigger state i'm not even
sure where i am now
looks like okay maybe michigan yeah
that'll zoom back out so that michigan
is properly framed
so that's a very convenient feature for
navigation especially if you're going to
do
any kind of visualization that involves
a particular region
all right so this might be a good
breaking point uh i guess i don't see
any new questions here um
maybe i'll give you a minute or two to
just play around with that and click
around a little bit
there'll be more
variations in the next few lessons
i think we're actually moving along at a
pretty good pace here
so let me know if i'm going too fast i'm
kind of anxious to try to get as much of
this in as possible
so i
don't see any complaints on on the chat
so i hope everything is kind of going
okay
okay um
and that's a good question uh actually
one of the features
about
the
in the
demonstration i showed uh
one of the key reasons we had to go with
that is we had
70 000
you know vaccine potential vaccine sites
to
to do data about and not it was not just
simply
um
just the geographic point we also had a
lot of data surrounding each point we
need to represent
so um
the
i
don't you know i think for the most part
what what a lot of this does because
this is actually written in react
is that it will
a lot of the the mapping functionality
is pushed to the browser
so
the performance actually has a lot to do
with who your end user is if they're on
a really old machine trying to run a
full browser can kind of bog down i've
noticed that when we're doing the
seventy thousand points
um
and actually on the on the this is the
question from toby in the chat
in fact i believe in the example i did
show
um
we did i did exactly that um
see this is still up here
if you recall when i start out here
actually if i start out the national
level
and then i
this is actually not really zooming in
i think you could actually trigger it on
the zoom level as well but
based on the click
it zoomed in and then showed county data
for that particular one you could
actually do you know you could say at
zoom level 5
show county level but that actually the
way you would do that is you would
change you would actually change the
shape you would push a different set of
shapes out at a different zoom level
and there's actually a question on
specific
research and i think that really has a
lot to do with
you know how you want to represent
things so
i'm not so sure about the
the glaciers but because that's
more of a
this works much better when you have you
know some kind of you know political
boundaries you could kind of do
you know you could map out things like
for global warming you could have you
know do countries by
you know their their carbon footprint
per capita or something like that can
kind of show at a glance who's
um
the the most um
uh what's the word um well
who are the
the good actors and the bad actors i
suppose um
but if you wanted to try to do you you
can lay on top of these things uh
you know
general graphics like you want to show
where
you've probably seen those maps about
you know
which regions have warmed and cooled and
that you'd have to draw your own
geographic boundaries
it can be done but that's sort of um
not the way
um
i at this point i you know i could
probably figure it out given enough time
but this is not the
kind of area where i've had experience
so
this work these work a lot better if you
have well-defined geographic features
that you're you're trying to represent
okay
so
um let me go ahead and move on to the
next one this is where we start uh this
is probably going to be sort of the last
equal basic
uh
capabilities and then we'll start
getting into the uh
uh
so stuff that might be more applicable
so this you know sort of the
uh the building block so i'm gonna load
in both the county and state data and
you'll see why
later so kind of where we left off in
the at the end of the last lesson
was
this map
and
i think i'd already gave you the uh
zoom
to bounce
on click is true
all right so that's
that gives us that interaction
see what the next thing
all right so
one thing we could you'll probably want
to do
um
is okay so
all right so let me back up here
first thing you probably want to do is
you may want to control
how this looks right now i you know it's
blue and that's sort of the default but
let's say i wanted to
change that a little bit
there is there's two ways there's in the
options
property there's actually a
element called
style and that's also a dictionary
let's say color equals
red
now it's
the boundary's red now the you'll notice
that sort of the the fill
is sort of a mixture of what you specify
the fill color
uh opacity and and so forth so because i
said it was red
it kind of became red but let's say now
i want
fill color to be purple
so it's now purplish if i've actually
changed the opacity
a fill opacity which is the
two one now now i'm going to make a
solid color
that is actually that purple
a few other properties here um
you can do the
i can change the weight i mean i don't
really i think this opacity of one is
pretty ugly so i'm going to change that
but
let's say the weight i
i want to make it really thin
make it one
so now this is a thinner boundary so
this is just sort of your first step at
styling
you can
color can be done you know using
our
so this is still red but it's using that
and there's also i think the other one
was uh
yeah so that's a little bit
more muted red
all three of those syntaxes are what i
just call the the css color syntax so
any of those things that you do in a css
file and if you're not familiar with css
you can
you know
you could just simply use this rgb and
then pick your rgb codes um especially
if you know you have some kind of um
styling guideline you have to adhere to
simply pick the
uh
the colors that are given to you
um the other one which i don't have
a whole lot of uh i i didn't use but
it's i've put it out there is that you
can also do a dashed array
let me copy that from my example
what this can do
is
it basically
makes your background uh
or your
makes the borders dashed as opposed to
solid
and again i i left the navigation in so
uh you can feel free to play around with
this um
yeah i'll give you a minute to play
around with it while i reset the next
exercise but uh
go ahead
um
you know so these are the five
properties you can play with uh
i did not
do anything with the border opacity you
might want to do that um
if you want the lines to be a little
lighter
okay so this is all i guess this comes
comes to
uh
lecture time now
problem is that leaflet is a javascript
uh
more specifically a react library so
you do you
if you really want to get into some of
the really
detailed
customizations you
you're going to have to do some
javascript
javascript is presented
it can be introduced in three ways and
there's a
library called dash extensions and if
you were
building this you
and not using the notebook you may have
to pip install this as well
it's
put out by the same guy who did the dash
leaflet so i think these kind of go hand
in hand
[Music]
and i don't really know that much about
javascript
so
i'm just going to give you my take on
my understanding
the arrow function is basically
let's say that you need to pass a
function
but the functionality is going to return
the same thing all the time
that's what the arrow function does and
i think it gets its name because that's
the way
one way of representing it in javascript
but basically
you take
um
in the case you'll see below
you're going to take
a dictionary
and you want to return that all the time
so you want your function to return the
same fixed dictionary every time
another way is to do
this assign function which is actually a
way of inlining
a javascript string
and the final way is that you can
specify a name space and i'll get into
this a little bit more because
um
that's actually my preferred way of
using it but
so so anyway namespace is a way of
actually referencing a javascript
library that you've loaded
okay so why is this important
especially at this point uh
one of the properties
i believe i listed up here
that i mentioned up here anyway
is this uh
did i mention it
oh it's because i had
undone my
markdown
yeah hover style
is another
property
that uh
okay i actually
miss
spelled it up there
that actually requires a javascript
function
so in this case
uh
i'm specifying hover style and i'm
passing it this function but it's going
to only return this dictionary every
time which sets weight to
six
okay so this is almost this is identical
to the previous example except i now
added this hover style so now when i
hover over a space you can see how the
thickness of the border
expanded
all right um you can do any of the other
all those five features that i mentioned
above you can uh
you can change that so you can do the
fill
green
no
see when i hover over it it's a
different fill color
um
[Music]
you
certainly can play around with that um
i'll give you another minute to tweak it
around but it's it's pretty much the
same you can uh
that's actually the fill opacity it's a
more interesting one
so let's say now if i hover over it i'm
going to make it a solid color
so
so uh you know
again this is how you style the the uh
hovering behavior
um it and changing the hover behavior is
good because it kind of gives the user a
cue as to
you know what they're on
okay
um
in my final version i actually
modified it a bunch of stuff
but
you can
that now we're going to start
you know interacting with the data more
the one thing you notice that's absent
here is that when i hover over it'd be
kind of nice to kind of
identify
the
the feature
that i'm hovering
over so right now there's no tool tip
so that's what the next
session is a section um
take a little okay so i'm just checking
for questions
okay uh since no one has any questions
i'll move on
so
tooltips is not something you actually
attribute to
the uh
actually has
nothing to do with the the geo json
layer
the way you add a tool tip is by
creating a column
in your data frame
called tooltip
so uh so here's where we do a little bit
of pandas i'm copying over my state's
data frame here
just so that in future exercises and i'm
not going to start adding a bunch of
extra columns so that way if i ever go
back to my states table it's still
pristine
uh so the first
tip is just simply to uh i'm going to
call it
this i'm going to create a new column
and it's i'm just going to assign it to
the name of the state
okay so that's all i've done now i'm
reverting back to my original colors and
lack of interaction
and now you can see that if i mouse over
i get the state
now this is not mutually exclusive with
the hover style i could also have the
hover style and do this at the same time
i should point out that this tool tip
even though it is in your data it's
html so if i wanted to do something a
little more elaborate
put a break in and then i want to say
the fips code for that state is
and then add
states and i think it was called state
fp
now when i do this
now i can represent the data
uh
so if you have a more elaborate set of
data you know you can
pass it to a python function it'll
format it all nicely for you and do all
the things you need
um
okay
um
and as you see that i left you that
example at the end just just
as a reminder that this
takes html formatting and you could do
you know you could color the text
whatever
all right um
okay so
next here okay so this is now the same
map as before
and you
we're probably going to start with this
quite a lot just as a starting point but
the only difference here i've wrapped
this whole thing inside a
div which is just you know html
container
and i've added a button here it's
labeled click me now right now it
doesn't do anything i click on it
nothing
but
i'm going to start to build it up
and so we'll do app
callback
and for my
and the syntax i believe is outputs
first so output
the output is i want to effect the g
adjacent layer so the layer is called
border
that's the
border so that's the id of my
dash component so this works with any
dash component
all together in this case it's
specifically a geo json
and the property i want to actually
change on this callback is the data
and as my input
i want
the
the id is button btn and this is
i probably should have named it
something else just to avoid confusion
this is just this name here
and the property for buttons again i've
mentioned this i think it before
it's a very generic
a lot of
dash objects have this nclix property
and click event clicks things n clicks
okay so that's
now this is a decorator
so
what i want is
um i believe i should
call it california because this what
this is going to do is it's going to
filter california now my first input
is
actually going to do it this way
n clicks
and i'm going to copy the body of this
because it's a bit
a little bit much
all right
and
10 clicks and clicks
all right so what this does is it um
one of the consequences of dash is it
actually will call all callbacks
initially unless you suppress it
uh and that gets into more detail than i
really want to go into here so basically
it may come back that nclix is actually
none
on the first try and so this is just to
avoid type errors
uh so basically what this is going to do
is it's just based on whether it's an
odd or even number click
it's going to go between
filtering on
my data to the fips code of 06 which is
california
or
or or it's going to show me
the full
u.s map here so i run this
and
if i do click me now
it shows california or not
all right i think the next
exercise i
okay yeah
so this is just uh this is one example
like for instance you may want to filter
your data later on you you know you may
do things as well as
have
data points within
the the city and you're going to want to
apply a filter and in sort of that
example i showed you at the beginning i
had filters for
community pharmacy and
different kind of health centers
as an example
all right um
okay so
now what i'm going to do with the
zoom control and you'll see why later
when on this sort of bonus section you
can kind of see highlighted here why i'm
not doing the whole us from this example
i'm going to isolate down to california
here
and
i've turned on something called the okay
so now
this is essentially the same model as
the one i gave you before the only
difference is between california now the
click now isolates down on san diego
county which is a county i work in
um
and
[Music]
first thing is i i added the click to
zoom on bounds just so that uh i wanted
to get into
the different counties i can navigate
that way
um
and by the way i mean i can actually
these maps are extremely detailed
um
if i zoom in all the way here you can
kind of see here the west health
institute which is where i'm actually
sitting currently
so just a little digression here and
just also to give you guys one more
chance to to play around a little bit
so anyway so what this does
i don't have assumed oh yeah
all right so
what this does is the same kind of
exercise here now
it's kind of uh especially from the
situation i was showing you it's kind of
irritating that i couldn't find my
correct zoom level
so there's actually something here
called
zoom to bounds and if i set that to true
what that does is anytime the data
changes it will resume
the
the map
based on
what data currently is in that geo json
layer
so right now it's california but if i
click it again it's
the only data in that geojson layer will
be the map of oh i need to run it
is san diego so it will zoom in on san
diego if i click it again that includes
all of california so now it centers
around all of california's data
this is this is a very uh helpful
feature especially if you have like
a menu to drive what
the user experiences or how to fill this
in
okay
since we are a little bit moving at a
pretty good pace here
i will go into this uh there was a
question about
geographic integrity
or the data
integrity now this is a problem i ran
into doing this uh
back
doing the visualization
that you saw at the beginning and that
is state of alaska is somewhat
problematic
uh if you just take it out of the box
you'll notice here that alaska
this is set at uh i do have that um
zoom to bounds
here
it's somewhat problematic because the
western aleutian islands
actually crosses that 180
degree longitude line so you'll see that
there's a part of it on the right
because this map wraps
this is where
on the right is where 179 is and on the
left is where -179 is and
you don't want that
that's really not a desired effect and
because it's doing a zoom to bound it's
trying to get everything into one frame
so that's why alaska is not
quite centered as you would expect
uh this click me button just
is to illustrate toggling between the
counties this is a random county i think
it's denali county
and so it's zoomed properly but the
016 which is the west
aleutians west i think it is county
it's this one and that's the one that's
causing all the zoom issues
uh the way i did it was i went to the
shapefile and i basically called these
things -181
etc
now if i were to take out that county
which is what this commented line is
now when i
use it
now when i view alaska this is now this
is sort of the effect you would have
expected initially you wanted you would
have expected to see it this way but
that western aleutians throws this whole
thing off
so i bring this up
i think the other place you might have
issues is if you're talking about
siberia it seems to cross that line as
well
there might be some other things
along some of these uh
island chains could run into that
problem so if you're working
with anything around the essentially
anything around the international date
line you do need to be careful that
about this wrap around effect
all right so uh it's a good time to
pause for a moment see if it catch your
breath
play with the visualizations for a
moment and see if you have any questions
i know so far it's been light on
representing data i've basically shown
you geographic regions and that that's
great if you're trying to show
different
zones perhaps where your data is already
geographic but uh say that you want to
marry your data with
geography and that's what the next
section will be on
alrighty
and we'll bring up the next one
all right well i am monitoring the
questions
uh periodically so especially between
exercises so uh if you do have questions
please feel free to post in the
chat all right
so
the next so now we're going to actually
start mixing data with uh
with these maps
um
probably one of the
most uh basic things to do it's called a
coral pleth map
it's basically you can think of it as a
geographic heat map
um
so first thing i'm going to do
okay i'm loading the state data
and this
this next csv file is actually in the
package i
provided but it's
and i grabbed it
last week so it's not up to date but
this is the from that uh coven
project at johns hopkins uh so it
includes all the so this
file contains
i should actually show what that has in
it
this has all the uh
some of the
covered related date
data now i think most of this is
cumulative over time so this is not the
daily snapshot
and
this is helpful because you see that
again all the states they have this fips
code
one thing you do have to worry about in
some of these files is like the fips
codes are
sometimes presented as strings and
sometimes as integers and so when you go
to do your join you have to make sure
they're the same type otherwise you
may have an improper join
okay so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to create this covered data frame
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
merge my state map which has the fips
code identified by state fp
and merge it with this
covet data table
where the fips code is
represented by
the um
by the the column fips
so
in essence i mean it includes a few
other things but what's important is
i got my cova data here
plus this geometry column
and so now i can map any of the
geographic
uh any of the cova data
to the geographic region
okay so um
the way
the uh
choropleth
map works is basically what i'm doing is
that style option we did in the last
lesson
i'm going to assign a function to it
based on the feature
and so this is where we started delving
into javascript and it's a little more
complicated than just being able to
supply an arrow function
at the same time i should also mention
that included with dash leaflet this is
not a native
leaflet component
the author created a color bar
component which is actually very
and so i presented here
in our case
what we're going to do is we're going to
chop our data up into little buckets
0 plus 10k plus 30k etc
so that's how my classes are going to be
defined i'm going to label my categories
this way
and
i think i stole this color scale from
the the example
in the documentation
um there's you know you can there's some
parameters here that allow you to
specify the dimensions of your color bar
and you'll have
you can
designate the position
on the map where you would like the
color bar to
to go
okay
so
now to the javascript and this is the
this is once you want to get to the you
know really cool and advanced
interactions
you don't have to be really heavy into
the javascript but you do have to apply
some of it
all right
so
um this is sort of the function now um
context will give you the um
i think the the feature which it comes
from
and
or oh context is the uh
the context of your particular layer in
our case the geo json and props are a
good property so you'll be able to
access a property called
hideout i'm not sure why you called it
hideout but
you will see here let me go to the
code and you'll see that where it's
specified you'll see that there's this
property i specify for the geojson layer
called hideout
what this is is a generic
option
javascript object or python dictionary
whichever way you want to call it
that is accessible from the context but
really serves no purpose it's a way for
you to pass something to the javascript
and so what
in this example we're going to pass
the color scale and that's that color
scale variable i gave you the classes
the reason uh
and i
and then the uh the style so i have an
initial style for my uh
for my map
but it's going to get modified
uh by this javascript program
and then in this case uh
i'm just gonna this will allow me to
change the uh
the metric i want to actually
base it on
so that's what this color prop is and
again this is highly lifted from the
from the documentation i varied it from
the one that's in there a little bit
okay so now backing up
this is a javascript program
uh
what i basically did in this first line
is i'm unpacking all the properties i
shoved in to the hideout
then i'm going to
take my value from the
color prop in this case the confirmed
cases property of my feature so the
feature is the row that got selected
so it's not just the geometry but it's
all the other data in that row so
i can use any of these
columns in there
um
let's see
all right and then all i'm doing is i'm
this all this it does is i'm trying to
determine which fill color i'm using
based on
where the value lies so if it's between
uh
ten thousand and thirty thousand i'm
going to use i think the second color
etc
that's all that does now this is the
using the assign feature and that's a
way of inlining it i personally
don't like that because
mixing languages in code makes it hard
to read and plus
your ide
doesn't really play nice with that
generally speaking it just as far as
python concerned it's concerned it's a
string so i i can't spot syntax errors
and stuff like that very easily
you'll see that in the package here
there's an assets directory and again
this is something i forgot to mention
but in dash every any javascript or css
in the assets directory gets
automatically loaded
um
so i created this one called the
choropleth demo
and so
this is this is the same file now i've
included the text here
in the notebook so it's a little easier
to discuss
so basically what follows this window
dot is the
name space and then the first
uh key here is the sub namespace and
that's all um
is the sub name space and then style
handler is the name of the function the
function so the way i reference this is
namespace well
choropleth demo
covid which is my namespace and sub
namespace and then the function itself
so that's the handle now both of these
blocks of code will work
it just depends on your preference uh
for the remainder of this the exercises
i'll probably use the inline just
because it's easier to demonstrate but i
think in production i would generally
prefer the namespace method
all right
so
with all that said and done okay so
let's see is there anything else i need
to mention about the code
so really the only things i've added is
hideout
and instead of style being mapped to
that dictionary it's mapped to this
function
so that oh
yeah so uh i think i mentioned it but
i'll reiterate it so what it i do is the
only style feature i'm changing based on
the value is the fill color
and so now when i graph this
have this kind of map
and so and not surprisingly the most
populous states have the most uh
case rates uh
most confirmed cases since the beginning
of the pandemic
um
this
you know
so this is sort of how you would start
out with uh you know first
one way of representing some of your
data
in a geographic form
okay so let's see
anyone have any questions at this point
i think we're doing
doing pretty good on time here um
okay um so this is probably the extent
this is the extent of what i'm going to
talk about uh
as far as sort of these boundary type of
data points
the remainder of this is actually going
to talk about
um uh yes
point data or scatter plots
um
all right so i am going to go to my
my next
lesson all right so this is going to be
the basic partial portions with uh
point data
okay so for this one i'm going to read
that u.s cities
and the comment here is i believe that
was sort of in their terms of
use which is that you just simply have
to state
the origin of the data again this all
goes back to attributions
um
all right uh so
to
just to kind of go back to what we did
with the boundaries
uh if you do point data
uh you can also
do the same uh trick with the tooltip
the tool tip is the name of the
um
if there's a column column in your data
called tool tips it's going to get
create a tool tip from that if there is
no
tool tip column it will not
so i'm going to go ahead and do that and
in addition since if i did all the
cities in this map it's going to
be
a mess
i'm going to isolate one city and the
reason for picking new jersey is after
playing with this with a lot of
different states it actually has the
wider widest diversity of population
density cities that makes any sense in
other words when i start coloring by
population density
it has the most colors it turns out that
most cities have roughly a fairly
consistent
density so
my maps initially started out looking
actually quite uh
monotone
monochrome
okay um
let's see all right so we'll start with
the basic scatter plot now there's this
um
there's this
property called point to layer
and i'm only assigning it to none at
this point
just because
i
wanted to remember to include it to be
quite honest
but i'm setting it and then just
so that you you know what it looks like
when you don't actually specify any
customization
all right so when i do that
with all the cities that's in this
database for new jersey
it looks like a a mess
all right now
it's less so when i you know when i
start zooming in
you can kind of see where the cities are
and i believe this is a city i forget
what the population cutoff is but this
file is populations over maybe 25 000.
but you can see that my tooltips work i
hover over and the uh the mark these
things are called markers the markers
are pinned at the location of the
of the city so you know
it's that tip which is and you can
specify on your marker where it's
centered you know so your hot spot
okay so this is
uh
not
you know
for this kind of graph it
if you don't have a lot of points this
is fine but if you want to get into
really
um
when you're plotting a lot of points on
the map
this obviously just looks cluttered and
pretty much not useful you you actually
rather have a point
okay so and i'm going to just copy the
code here
from here but
so point to layer what that is is a
javascript function telling it at a give
given point plot
what to show
all right so i'll go over this uh
there's a little bit of um
well
a little well actually this one's okay
and there isn't later on there will be
some that are
um creating the the icons out of css
there is a circle marker that's provided
as part of leaflet now this l dash l dot
i'm sorry is uh indicates it's out of
that leaflet library
uh you can look up in that leaflet
documentation the specific options for
the circle marker but basically here
we're saying the we want the fill
opacity to be one
it's not going to be stroked which means
no border or outline on it
and the radius will be five now if i do
that instead of
the um
these kind of pins
i'll get a circle
and so this is what it looks like
so this is a little bit better
but still you probably
you may want to do a little bit more
than this
okay um because it's still just it's a
bunch of blue dots and you know we're
not conveying any data actually i'm just
showing you where this
city locations
so
the next thing i'm going to do is
okay i think from here also from here on
in
much more this is going to be canned in
the notebook just because it's just
too much to type by hand
and kind of demonstrating it to you so
so it's going to follow more of the
format now that i'm going to show you
the code and try to explain it and then
run it as opposed to
um
you know i'll modify it on the fly
now you can you know you can still
feel free to you know muck around with
this and tweak it
um
okay so
i should point out this this chroma
library is actually
it's a javascript library that's used
for color scale so
you kind of seamlessly go from one color
to another so
in this case we're going from red yellow
green blue to purple which is rainbow
colors but what the chroma scale will do
is if i pick a point that's between red
and yellow it'll find the appropriate
shade
that'll make it look right
okay and then we're gonna create a color
bar now this
basically um
you specify the color scale
and uh your dimensions
okay but of course the meat of
everything is this javascript function
point to layer
so
um
okay again we pull out our critical
properties from the hideout
what this is doing is it's actually just
picking the color it's very much like
the previous example it's picking out
the color based on the color property so
instead of doing
the
the discrete bins that we did last time
this is actually trying to do a sliding
scale of color
okay and then the only difference now is
when i create my circle marker i'm
specifying this specific fill color
unlike what i did in the previous
example where the fill color was not
specified
so
and i believe the rest of the code runs
the same the reason why i
made a separate copy is that i wanted to
add the color bar here
so now
again most of the density is actually
now most of the cities aren't that dense
but you can kind of see near new york of
course it's starting to get a little red
now
now here we're actually expressing some
data
via visualization at a glance you can
tell where
population is denser
in the cities
and i can go in and look at
it and it's actually a few cities uh i
believe one of these cities actually i
think i looked it up has the highest
population density in the us
i was actually kind of surprised by that
i thought it would be like manhattan or
something but um
all right
so this
this kind of concludes the way uh what i
have on just plotting data by points
right off but
let's see anybody have any questions or
want a little time to tweak this
all right
it will go to our
our final lesson and this is actually
probably the
the singular thing that caused us to go
with
um uh with dash leaflet when we were
trying to do our visualization and that
is a its ability to do clusters now
clustering is not part of dash leaflet
it actually uh
is from a
open source library
produced by mapbox actually called
supercluster
and
some of the advantages here is it does
the clustering on the
the client side so that your server
isn't busy running clustering every time
someone clicks on something so that's
all done on the client side which also
makes the clustering operation
run much smoother and faster
okay so to start off with
i've got the same
example as last time um oh i do want to
mention before i go too far i don't
remember if i did in the previous lesson
but i did convert
without telling you guys uh the data to
geo buff which is done with this helper
function applied and
supplied in this module dash
leaflet express
it's just a few that it just
contains a few helper functions it also
contain one of the
uh convenient helper for creating a um
discrete color bar
and you may have note you may have
noticed that i kind of glossed over that
as well
so this was our previous
uh okay so this is all the the setup
that we've used to our previous
uh
point
or scatter plot basically
and
this is what it looked like
where we left off
now
uh you may notice i snuck in a couple
parameters here
um
and let's go over the part
first of all there's this property
called cluster so if i make that true
now this is what happens whenever points
are close together it puts up a cluster
instead so these red dots aren't really
close close enough to the threshold of
uh
of
the uh other cities so that they
stand out but
inside each of these
like this one with the four that shows
that there are four
um
there are four cities within that
cluster now as i zoom in they break up
and it's based on a uh um
a proximity
at the level you're at
so it's a very good way to kind of you
know when when you have regions of high
density points you can capture it with a
single
single marker and then when it's lower
density you can actually have the
individual points
a few of the properties that go with
that there's this thing called super
cluster options which is actually how
you specify some of this now radius is
the thing that
dictates how i um
and how close i cluster so if i change
this from 40 to 100
much fewer clusters because it's
covering a wider
region of the cluster
um
max zoom is or let's see
i think it's
min zoom
is the uh
normally comes in we start out at zoom
level four or
oh this is in level seven so if i go
uh i think it's eight
that tells you at beyond that zoom level
it will no longer cluster
uh did i have it the other way around
it might be maximum
apologize i don't i it's not something i
actually use but uh
yeah you see at that level um
when i reached so i'm start out at seven
and at eight it will still
let's see this is seven at eight
it's still clusters but at nine it
exceeds the max zoom and now it will not
cluster
so that's a that's a
something allows you to control the zoom
the other thing is min points is
sometimes useful
let you cluster
let's say five that means that all
clusters have to have at least five
points in them
so if i start zooming in
uh
it'll start breaking them up
sooner because it no cluster will have a
number large smaller than uh
um
smaller than five
okay
um
let's see one other thing um
oh yeah i did not mention this i did
also sneak in the zoom to bounds on
click if you actually have that turned
on
the um the behavior is if you actually
click on the cluster itself
it will zoom in
to the next to the zoom level
that would it's kind of hard to explain
it it basically zooms in
deep enough so that
that cluster breaks
so not necessarily all the way down to
nothing but um
so like the 62
61 it'll
zoom in until that 61 becomes a bunch of
other clusters
and so forth
and that's actually a
convenient behavior as well
all right
okay so uh so you can kind of play
around with the clustering and i um
the next example
is
basically i i just wanted to you know so
far we've dealt so much with the
interactions that are built into dash
leaflet and not talk so much about
the interaction with say other parts of
your your visualization
i just want to kind of remind everyone
that um
every property including this
true
or most property i shouldn't say every
are um
are addressable via the callback so
for example
here what i've done here is
on that layer i've made the cluster
property
adjustable and it
basically toggles between true and false
so now when i do the
click me button
it goes between the two and i believe
it'll actually preserve the zoom level
and you can do that with
anything you can change you know
you can change the different options you
can change uh
the um
the zoom resolution i guess the one
thing and i don't have any material for
this but we are
that
i hadn't mentioned is that
we don't have any examples of using the
you know clicking on the feature causing
a uh
causing a reaction somewhere else
okay so the final topic here that i have
prepared anyway
is customization of that cluster layer
you may want to change the appearance um
so i have
this is sort of a scale of how i would
have
taught it but there's just so much to
type
so the first version of this cluster to
layer what this does is it puts a custom
icon
now this icon is created using css and
html styling and kind of
uh you probably don't really need to
know much about this beyond
the fact of you know of being able to
copy this from somewhere um but if you
are gifted in that you know in
all kinds of the css stylings you can
make arrows and stuff like that yeah you
can use this kind of template
uh the other thing you can also do is
you can actually
these markers can also be
your urls to particular graphics so i've
seen
different types of pins for instance
based on your application there are
examples of that in the
documentation so if we've run this one
with the cluster to layer version one
oh yeah i guess i should back up a bit
cluster to layers like the point layer
function pretty much analogous
um
so if you supply that function know that
property
now if you get the this nice circle with
the number inside and
as you can see in my example here yeah
the color on the circle is black and we
made this the
size 40 by 40.
you can play around with that if you
want
the second iteration here but now i'm
scaling this based on the average
density so it matches sort of that color
scale we have
um
i won't go into too much detail most of
this is pretty straightforward um
oh but there's one thing uh from this
index variable that you that the
function does get passed you can run
this thing called get leaves
which will retrieve all
the features within that cluster so if
you have 10 points in there you can get
access to the 10 points and in this case
we want we get the 10 points
and we want to extract the color dense i
mean the population density from that
and then average them out
actually now that i think about this is
probably not the right kind of way to do
the average because you should weight it
based on population two but
that's
kind of
another matter
uh
so anyway the results of this
we did layer number two
uh-oh what happened now
oh i didn't run it
we do layer number two now the circles
tend to match the color bar to it to
some extent
so
if i go in a little bit closer
and remember our hot spot was over here
near new york you can kind of see now
the average density is getting a little
higher
okay the final enhancement
is that you notice
that while
while going over the points themselves
have that tooltip
there's no
tooltip based on the cluster
so
the cluster gets past this thing called
feature now the cluster itself is a
feature and it's not related to anything
from your data specifically except
the leaves make up this feature
so
but it works exactly the same way you
just assign the property and it's really
just this one line
you're adding another column to the
feature and you're not only a tool tip
so that's the same thing throughout the
whole thing if you're doing the tooltip
in this case i'm going to
put the number of points in that cluster
under number and then the mean value
over here
so if i do that
now i hover over
oh did i not oh i didn't change the
sorry i did not change the
customer layer function
now you see i have a tool tip and
so that's all the prepared material i
have um take questions if you want we
have about 10 minutes left
yeah so uh dr lou i was wondering how
have you uh found any work where we can
do the
uh analysis of how much time it will
take for that depending upon data like
if you want to plot large geographical
area how much time it will take
and like how fast it is something like
that
uh not really any analysis as i said we
needed to have 70 000
data points
uh loaded
in what felt reasonable to the person
and by comparison when we tried uh like
taking a notebook and deploying voila
for instance
it took 15 minutes and that's yeah we
had to be in on the order of seconds and
so
um
you you may if you have a very large
data set or a lot of geographic regions
you may have to play some tricks to
push out only the data that's necessary
one of the things i did not do here is i
did not drop any columns for data that i
wasn't representing
uh when you want to go into production
and really streamline it you only want
in your
your geojson to contain only the columns
that you're going to be manipulating
just thinking uh
the only other thing i guess i did not
show
was
i don't know if i could
base it off of an example here
but
you can um
one of the the really
useful things let me see if i can
quickly change this example
uh
i don't know counties
and change this to
[Music]
um
click
this might be a way that you might uh
let's see let's just call this thing uh
i'm not going to rename too much
there's something because i i feel like
when after going through this again one
of the things that i'm probably missing
out on a little bit is how you would use
the map to drive other
other parts of visualization like maybe
a graph on the side
so uh
let me just see
i do this
i won't rename anything uh let's just do
so the input will be
actually do this first
this might throw a trace back
i don't remember how it comes exactly
so if i click say a county
i'm not sure i got this done right
well anyway this is sort of what would
happen and let's i'm just going to
this i probably can't get the code to
work right now but uh
you might do something like input
or in this case i would say
return um
i might do something like
[Music]
the input
and figure one of the fields that name
maybe
so what this would do is when i click on
the county
it would then
set the text to the name of the um
see then the specific row gets passed
back to me
and then the
i don't remember if name was actually in
the row but then you could actually use
that and say
filter a graph on the right
instead of you know right now it's just
very simple i was hoping to be able to
just
print the name of the county below here
but
oh
maybe it would maybe it does work um let
me
let's see if that even works i didn't
even see that it
done anything
uh that probably traced back yeah it's
not
returned none anyway
um
yeah
so
that's i i think that's part of uh you
know i've seen examples like using other
tools like tableau where you might
actually have a graph on one side of
data on uh graph uh
map on one side and graph on the other
and you want the map to drive the graph
and the graph to drive the map and you
can do that here it's just a matter of
using these inputs and outputs um so
there is one question
from alex okay uh how's the output of
this work used on production in your
case
okay so the way we've done this in this
case
we're actually using aws serverless to
deploy
you can
at the heart of this this is just a
flask server so you can spin it up on
your own server you can
i've done it in ecs containers
which are basically docker containers on
aws
but the specific graphic i showed you at
the beginning was
using serverless which uh employed aws
lambdas
one downside to that was that it does
have a cold start if it hasn't been run
for a while and that
always bugged me a little bit that's why
if you actually go to the site
uh it's a little bit slow coming up and
the
we threw in a um
an initial spinner graphic just so that
the user doesn't
think nothing's working
if you want a highly interactive and
highly responsive
deployment i would do something that
you know to try to mitigate the startup
time
uh an answer to that
last question it is actually a flask
uh application if you actually look at
dash
it sits on top of flask
and
you can actually
access the flask
server underneath dash if you wanted to
if you needed to do things like apply
authentication for instance uh you could
still use flask login
and then throw dash on top of that so
um
so all of this is actually flash if you
really look at the workings
it
it pushes out a dash leaflet library and
not actually a leaflet js library
and
controls it from there and it just does
all that for you but you could you know
you could deploy by
a flash server that throws up a leaflet
jas and a bunch of your own javascript
and do the same thing it's just uh
obviously from um
if you're you know if you're a web
application programmer then
that would be
what you might do but you know coming
from the side of being a data scientist
you kind of want
as much of that handle for you as
possible
so
so i think we are closing to our uh time
so if we don't have any further question
uh
yeah i think one question pop up
yeah can the villains do the top of some
live dynamic data source making that
negative changes
uh yeah um
yeah i mean if as long as you have the
appropriate trigger
in the uh dash side uh
yeah that's entirely possible i mean
from within the framework you saw in uh
one of my examples of filtering you
um
the original example of filtering where
i you know chose california not
california with the data
uh that's all within the the uh
the
data that had loaded but you could
dynamically change that data and any
kind of change trigger there are there
are callbacks so that you can push
to the output
um
that that
you know like json
geojson output layer as long as you set
that any callback can trigger that so
yes you can make this uh
a real-time updating now there are some
tricks with the plumbing of all that
um
you know i don't um pretend to know how
your data is your your updated data is
actually getting into the server but it
is it can be done that way
uh oh i should bring up i guess the last
slide was just uh if you do have other
questions you think of something later
um yeah i'd go to the github uh probably
the best way is to
post an issue on the github um
repo that's in in your materials in that
questions uh notebook and the reason for
doing that is that
that way um
you know others can see the question and
might answer their questions uh and also
i believe pi data global has um i'll be
on the slack channel for a while so you
can ask me questions there too if you
want
i don't remember i thought there's they
said there was supposed to be one
specifically for the workshop but if
there isn't just you know just at me of
the on the slack channel i'll try to get
to you
definitely for the next couple hours
anyway yeah
okay so i think we are now about to
close our time so yeah i will take
opportunity to thank dr lou for your
interacting and this is very important
topic on my visualization nowadays lots
of my
visualization techniques are coming and
requirements are also coming so thank
you i hope everyone have enjoyed so
thank you have a nice day all right well
thank you all for coming